when I first said I was getting indie
sports a lot of the people I spoke with
were former professional owners of
franchises and traditional sports former
teammates I remember telling Shaq I told
Kobe they didn't understand what it was
but within a year Shaq became part of an
eSport organization Kobe is exploring it
we have a lot of traditional athletes
that actually their own or have invested
in eSports teams
[Music]
for as long as videogames have existed
there's been a competitive gaming scene
but if you recognize the potential of
gaming as a spectator sport it's only
over the last decade with the rise of
streaming technology an influx of
investment that eSports have been able
to grow to what they are today many of
these investors come from an unlikely
place the world of traditional sports
today we're talking a former basketball
pro Rick Fox owner of the team 100
thieves nadeshot
and the assistant manager of the Golden
State Warriors Kirk wake up to examine
the connection between esports and
traditional sports organizations like
the NBA so coming from the NBA for
myself personally having been a part of
a competitive environment on a large
scale globally and entering eSports and
having to both you know seeing both
communities as having their own value
and their own expression of competition
I love that I saw in so many ways the
similarities I saw two ecosystems
standing alone and really impacting the
entertainment value for viewer I think
it's really interesting that there have
been so many NBA owners and NBA players
that had invested in eSports
holistically but for me it's actually
much broader than that there was a
stigma or a stereotype behind gaming for
a very long time that's you're in your
mom's basement Dorito crumbs Mountain
Dew all day every day and that's what
gaming was but now what people don't
realize or what they're quickly
realizing is that video games are pop
culture now all of our athletes and
artists I have that are now coming into
popularity and building their careers
have started with video games they grew
up with that personally I've been a
video game player since I was a teenager
so the understanding that the games that
I love and play had evolved to a place
where you could compete professionally
and have a career was very interesting
to me because it represented the next
generation of professional athletes and
gamers I work for the Warriors in
basketball and my job spans a lot of
things it's fans the actual basketball
side it spans business it spans kind of
new ventures and we are looking for
things that really had a parallel to
what we were doing we're an
entertainment company
and gaming is huge League of Legends is
huge
I am the VP of eSports for clutch gaming
and the Houston Rockets the thing that
really wakes me up and gets me to sleep
it in the day it's a sustainability of
our organization and the long-term
growth of the organization we all want
to be just a flash in the pan with the
influence of traditional sports
organizations and the establishment of
franchise teams the infrastructure
around LCS is evolving but what goes
into running an eSports organization how
is the support effecting the LCS and how
are the conditions changing for players
as the 2018 season the sort of format
for picking teams changed from a
promotion and relegation system where
teams have come from the lower leagues
and take your spot to one a franchising
where teams actually bought in bought
their spots and could hold on to it for
several years or or forever based on how
things go
historically a long time ago when you
saw eSports teams come to fruition they
weren't making a ton of money and now
that you have capital being invested
into the teams you have a lot more
operational ability to go out and sign
better players and work on stronger
branded deals with non-endemic sponsors
that are coming into this space with the
backing of the Golden State Warriors we
have so many resources at our disposal
we're able to think long term about
things we're able to think about
building something that can last this
includes things like building out a
practice facility making sure our
players are housed supporting them with
coaches and having general managers that
are paying attention to their travel and
then getting them into the competition's
they need to be in the vast majority of
costs it with regards to an eSports
organization staff right and that's just
true and I think most industries but
particularly in eSports players are
expensive and it's and they deserve to
be expensive it's it's a free market
there they're working really hard and
they should make them levy to all the
NBA investors that are investing in the
LCS definitely helps LCS become
sustainable since before we didn't
really have that good of a salary and it
was more beneficial to stream compared
to being salaried as a player but now
that all the investors are here
definitely helps a lot by being able to
just focus on the competitive aspect and
then on top of that the operational
costs social media of the type of
content we're creating the video content
that stuff needs to level up over time
and that requires more investment into
cameras
people he sports is 24/7 365 days and we
are building an industry and building on
an industry foundation that's been laid
long before I showed up but what what
I'm hoping to do is add value to this
community of eSports by delivering on
the same passion the same energy and
there is no there's no off days so now
that we've identified the similarities
between eSports and traditional sports
the connection is a whole lot more clear
but what are those who are investing all
their time energy and money see in the
future the first thing I think I'd love
to see it's just much more understanding
among the greater world of the different
opportunities in eSports
we need accountants we need graphics
designers we need musicians we need
people who can you know run our PR run
our social media we could use everyone
and we can just really use good people
the future of Reid sports for me is
really important just because it is
giving me an opportunity to build a
career around something I'd love to do
and of course I want to build a great
financial business so it's really really
important for me is to be able to help
young kids who were in the same position
that I was continue to do what they love
to do I grew up with the stigmas around
video games and I hated them and so you
know my journey is simply just to
continue to shine a positive light on
the impact of what what this industry is
doing for my son what it's doing for
other kids what it's done for me in my
life in retirement as an NBA player
we're not just putting in money but
we're putting in time we're putting in
man-hours and we're putting in like our
own sweat and blood and ultimately it's
gonna be worth it
I truly believe eSports would be a
top-three sport in the world in the next
five to ten years every large gaming
event has at least one thing in common
cosplayers in the next episode of this
series we talked to some incredible
cosplayers about what they love about
their craft and dive into their
workshops to see how they become our
favorite characters
[Music]
you